spring and Kerry would former cub great
what do you do you know anything about
Pokemon go I'm not ever gonna play it do
you do you have kids who played it I
have trip they do not play yeah they're
not aware I've got a ten eight and six
year old and I've tried to sell CDs and
Java keeping them off the electronics
how you feeling I'm doing good how are
you I'm good
did you have surgery oh yeah yeah had
surgery about two weeks ago on your
ankle my right ankle and I destroyed my
ankle on the back of a surf boat so just
messing around freaking Oh No so there's
no comeback
no comeback no I don't know kind of like
it was like the Jason Kendall injury
remember him when he shot it man foot
around he made it back he came back yeah
that was so yeah but he was younger
though he way young how bad was that
when he he he stepped on first base and
cracked his ankle yeah her leg broke his
broke his ankle and I thinking in
compound fracture the bone shot out and
everything it was yeah that was brutal
what was the words early in his career
yeah and he was up there for a batting
title I think yeah the worst injury you
ever saw probably well I didn't see that
one live live Chad Fox threw a pitch he
had a screw in his elbow and Chad Fox
threw a pitch and I was in the first
third-base dugout he could hear it snaps
from the from the dugout was a pretty
nasty one I was fortunate didn't see a
whole lot of bad things on the field um
no I had a second baseman that caught a
morandini knee I think was Chad Myers
caught more and Dinis knee and had a big
big knot on his on his head it looked
like I'm in that boxing match with it
Tyson or somebody was a really critical
maybe he has a big knot on his head they
kept trying to squeeze it down Hasim
Rahman that's it there you go
yeah we were gonna have young we were
talking about what happened with the
pirate pitcher and we just had him on
last hour had to come backer and it was
over a hundred miles an hour is it is it
me or everybody realizing everybody's
throwing hard the ball was coming off
the bats a lot faster than it used to
hey it's scary there's no question the
guys are hitting worth they wanted
harder and they're hitting it harder um
you know that's kind of always been the
saying if you throw enough of them guys
can they can they can stout tip a bullet
I mean they can time just about anything
if they see enough of them so they're
going to hit it even though these guys
are all throwing harder these guys are
putting them out on it and it's a scary
thing by the time you let go of the ball
and the ball comes off the bat you're
literally 50 feet from the from the
contact maybe less in some cases
depending on how long your stride is um
you don't you have actually you have
zero time to get out of the way did you
ever have one of those moments where
your life passed in front of you I had a
I had caught one near the ear and got
hit in the legs in the mire league and I
got hit in the feet all the time trying
to stop stuff but I was fortunate where
I didn't get anything I've only had one
that was near the near the head but I
tell you what I when I would fall asleep
on a plane or something I would have
that dream where I would slit and throw
my whatever I was holding my hand
everything would go fly you jerk so bad
I was having a little dream was gonna
come back her happened all the time I
had more dreams about it than it
actually encounters but did you when
bonzers at the plate your face and bonds
did you ever think if this guy hits gets
one a liner I mean he could take my head
off oh absolutely yeah absolutely him
McGuire pull holes these guys when these
guys were in their primes you don't but
I just I pitched those guys inside you
right I lived I lived inside you can't
hit a ball back at the pitcher at 100
miles an hour if you're getting jammed
or the balls in on you I mean I just
don't it just can't happen so I had the
guys that actually thought about it were
bonds pools McGwire a little bit Griffey
but you had to kind of get you could get
him out of way but you really had to
pitch him into so these guys would get
extension when you get extension and
hear that strong and you hit the ball
that clean those are the guys that
scared me Lance Berkman getting an
extended hidden balls back at you that
those guys were scary because they hit
it so hard cliff Floyd was another guy
to hit the ball so hard I mean they all
hit the ball hard but these guys are
just and it sounds different it comes
off the bat different and
those particular guys I made sure that I
did not leave anything out over the
plate especially anything soft and a lot
of times I stayed inside with those guys
you face bonds 21 times did I yep
7 for 21 no homers 3 RBIs I'll take that
you own Barry Bonds I'll take that yeah
wait you didn't even know if you gave up
a home run to him I knew I didn't give
up a home I didn't know his average or
how many about I never give up a homer
to him or McGwire or Sammy obviously I
played with Sammy but you read that
sound I'm ever asking Greg Maddux what's
a homeland sound like he said two cards
crashing what what what's it what's a
home run sound like to you when you
throw up and you don't even turn around
you just I don't even know it just
sounds like sometimes I mean depends
it's like a gunshot sometimes it's just
loud and POW and you don't even have to
look it just sounds different than the
rest of them they hit it in the sweet
spot they catch it right out in front of
the plate and I just got a different
sound and you know it as soon as you
hear it you hope that it's low enough
where it hits off the sense but yeah you
know it's gone when you hear it did you
ever have that moment where you just
want to crawl off the mound where you go
what am i doing out here yeah a few
times yet towards you to my career for
sure but I always tell I used to always
tell my my my wife at the time I'm like
there's not a lonelier feeling than
being standing in front of 42,000 people
with bases loaded and no outs there's
not a there's not a worse place to be so
you know but as I got older and played a
little bit longer I was chanting kind of
changed my thinking so hey I'm only two
pitches away from getting out of this so
that was early in the career but no I
think there was times at the end of my
career where you just go out you're
embarrassing yourself and you just want
to yeah this game is tough man this is
it's a hard game to play and at this
level too so there's times where you you
wouldn't be normal she didn't have
stretches where you just the game
frustrated you so much you wanted to
just walk away
he's Kerry Wood the former Cubs all-star
pitcher joining us Dan Patrick show but
if you were coming up now it feels like
Tommy John is a rite of passage for
every one of these kids they guys are
getting it done before
and might get it done a couple of times
but where are these like syndergaard it
he just it can't continue this way right
I mean you just continue to throw that
hard you know that that long well I mean
well that's kind of always been a
thought right I feel like my body broke
down because of how hard I threw but I
you look at it now it's not I don't look
at it that way I look at it just my body
broke down because I didn't work hard
enough to to be able to go out and throw
that hard for that long I kind of look
at it and I didn't put the work and
these guys today they've got it their
own different programs they these guys
are just getting there in such better
shape than we were and and and not you
know not all of us we obviously have
guys are in really good shape but these
guys have really bailed them their diet
and their the opportunities they have in
the clubhouse to house you know chefs
and and all these things they're forum
and they're taking full advantage of it
and these guys are in tremendous shape
and I know what it takes now to to go
out and pitch you 220 innings and you
know syndergaard is a guy with size and
obviously isn't that great of shape and
but I look at Jon Lester on our squad
and I look at John Lackey and obviously
airy out of these guys are just animals
and they and they feed off each other
and they've got ham on the mix now and
Hendrix is a big kid so these guys are
they're putting the work in and you know
so far so good with Arrieta but I mean
these guys are they're just on a
different level I think as far as the
workout their diet is there's concerns
when we were on anyway Curt Schilling
said yesterday that there's not that
much of a difference once you get over
95 miles an hour because I asked him you
know his Chapman really throwing 105 and
he said yeah I think he is but do you
agree if you're throwing 97 or you
throwing 99 or a hundred it doesn't
matter fairly Steel's got in the box off
those guys lately III would think that I
always written hitters to talk about in
the dugout saying 90 91 to 94 is not
that big of a difference you get you go
from 94 to 96 or 93 to 95 that that's a
jump that's a difference that they they
could see and they recognize that was
different I didn't have too many guys
that I came back and said he's throwing
104 it looks like it's 96 you know I
I didn't have that effect but these
these guys are I mean it's always been a
hit he's been impressive to me since
since the first time I step in the
batter's box so I don't understand how
these guys can hit even touch 95 and now
you got Chapman coming in doing 104 106
it's gonna hurt up but it definitely
looks different I mean it's it's when
you see it leave his fingers and it's
hitting the glove before he finishes his
follow-through it's like that's that's
for him and I would have to believe that
looks harder than 96-97 but I think
anything over 95 96 isn't that next is
in that next level explain this to me
that when the guy homers and then the
pitcher hits the next guy up what did
that guy do wrong that he got hit
understand tennis yeah it's it's a silly
kind of a thing pitcher that's an ego
thing right I mean it's it's but did you
ever do it the unwritten rule did I hit
yeah but when I was younger and didn't
learn how to do that properly um if you
didn't like something you waited till
that guy came up again or used to get
him out right yeah yes um you know it
became not so much you throw a guy's are
you not guys down because something they
did against me later in my career became
unprotected my teammates now I'm not
worried about my ego or just God took me
deep I left it out over the plate he
should have hit it over the fence you
know that's not that's my fault I'm not
gonna hit him because I left something
on the plate maybe I didn't like to
dance whatever you know that's the game
that's the way the game is now but I
think I learned later that you know you
learn as you as you played play the game
longer you use those senses to protect
your teammates and obviously you know if
you if you're not comfortable on the
mound you need to establish inside and
not guys down I think that you know that
that that goes hand in hand would
haven't success on the mound as being
able to be comfortable out there
obviously these you know the hitters is
trying to be as comfortable as he can in
the box but I always tried to slip that
role and if I was uncomfortable facing
somebody I would I would like to send
one inside just to put the ball back in
my court and maybe make them a little
bit more uncomfortable well you're
you're you were able to throw inside now
you can't throw inside so these guys go
up to the plate and there's nothing you
don't have that fear factor well yeah
you can't double up in there and you can
if you don't like the guy dive you can't
hit him because
both teams get a warning and then that
affects the game and I mean that we talk
about guys getting hit in the head and
pitchers they I needed that I needed to
pitch guys inside I want to always leave
everything out over the plate I mean I
always looked at at numbers when I was
coming into a series if you know if I
come in and pools is hitting 330 well
okay pools is covering the outside part
of the plate if you sit in three
thirties covering the outside part of
the plate so I obviously got to go
inside and that even makes your margin
fare even smaller when he's on fire you
had a such a small window to get him out
but it definitely wasn't what wasn't
down in a way and those guys from I
wasn't pitching those guys down there
anyway I said they want to get drilled
in the face but you needed to you needed
to be able to make them uncomfortable
and and I'm not sure if that's if that's
the same now so I don't know I think
pitchers are more vulnerable with no on
the ball harder and they're obviously
hitting harder so either we let these
guys kind of police this game a little
bit more like they used to obviously I'm
not saying throw it guys and hit guys
and you don't want to injuries and but I
also don't want to have to see you know
a League rule come in where they put
helmets on pitchers and change the game
because because guys are getting hit so
I think there's you know we changed the
whole slide in its second base rule for
me is as changing the game it changed
the game I'm okay with replays so I
think it it levels the playing field as
far as keeping acute you know everybody
wants to do a good job and make that
right call but changing the game and
changing the slide rules at second base
and an employ for me is that's part of
the game you were taught and literally
got to turn a double play before or
you're going to get taken out so
obviously again you don't want to
injuries you know one guys getting hurt
but I just don't like to see obviously I
want my mom all my pictures and players
just be safe but also want to keep the
the way the games been played for over a
hundred years you know look at your the
old man now you're yelling people kids
get off your lawn
hey good luck with rehab they're on the
ankle appreciated good to talk to you
good to catch up with you winning good
talking to you is always there the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you